one of the key things that's happening
in the world right now is there's a
renewed interest in energy independence
given the russia ukraine conflict and
the fact that so much oil and natural
gas comes out of that region there's a
lot of people scratching their heads
saying hey shouldn't we actually be
dependent on ourselves for all of our
energy production having to rely on
countries like russia probably not a
good idea and so naturally that leads to
a conversation around nuclear power
there's all sorts of different
approaches that have been taken globally
places like germany who literally have
been shutting down nuclear power plants
and going ahead and actually increasing
their dependence on russian oil hasn't
turned out so well for them the united
states we haven't really been so
pro-nuclear also we haven't necessarily
been shutting down tons and tons of
plants but we definitely haven't been
building new ones so ultimately this
leads to a decision are we going to be
pro-nuclear as a country or are we not
if you're serious about climate change
if you're serious about energy
independence i think you naturally end
up being pro-nuclear and so the current
presidential administration president
biden and his team they're launching a
brand new 6 billion effort to save
distressed nuclear power plants now i
don't necessarily always agree with what
the president does but you got to give
him kudos for this he's a very very
intelligent decision to continue to make
investments in nuclear power within the
united states now let's take a look at
the nuclear power situation though there
are 55 commercial nuclear power plants
93 nuclear reactors across 28 u.s states
nuclear power already provides about 20
percent of electricity in the u.s and
about half the nation's carbon free
energy but most of them were built
between 1970 and 1990 and it's costing
more and more to operate them as they
get older and older infrastructure so
then if we take a look that the only
nuclear power plant in the united states
under construction is in georgia but
there's a dozen u.s commercial nuclear
power reactors that have closed in the
past decade before the license has
expired and that's largely due to
competition from cheaper sources of
energy massive operating losses or the
cost of major repairs and so we have to
decide if we're gonna be pro nuclear how
the hell can we make the economics work
well president biden and his
administration are stepping in with six
billion dollars to help prevent the
shutdown of future nuclear power plants
and to offset some of those major
operating losses if we then go and we
take a look the energy secretary making
the point that u.s nuclear power plants
contribute more than half of our carbon
free electricity president biden is
committed to keeping these plants active
to reach our clean energy goals we're
using every tool available to get this
country powered by clean energy by 2035
and that includes prioritizing our
existing nuclear fleet to allow for
continued emissions free electricity
generation and economic stability for
the communities leading this important
work now ultimately it is not a
coincidence that all of a sudden nuclear
has gotten back in vogue people are
really pro-nuclear because they're
seeing what's happening in russia
ukraine germany and elsewhere the united
states must become energy independent we
have the ability to do it but we've got
to embrace nuclear power and we have to
start to make the investments today this
stuff doesn't happen overnight it takes
time the united states can be the leader
of nuclear power we just have to have
the political will and the appetite to
do the hard work to make it happen hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time